frosch im hals
warum sagt man frosch im hals ist aber
auch egal meine lieben freundinnen nicht
aber heute herzlich willkommen heißt und
seiner neuen episode ebay fällt mit luca
schreiende begeisterung
ich bin neuerdings gangster deswegen
habe ich eine kapuze auf staaten direkt
mit dem ersten teil meiner lieben freuen
uns dass dieser hier dort schreibt
nämlich eine person momo in wäre der
stuhl noch zu haben und ist dieser
soweit intakte gruß senden was ist
intakt du fest wann wo wie ok sagt
bringen und schmeißen eine presse
statt direkt richtig freundlich rein ins
video hier verkauft jemand eine fliese
denkt man vielleicht auf den ersten
blick
es ist allerdings keine herkömmliche
viele sondern es ist die beste fliese
man muss allerdings selber aus boden
reisen
so aus dem boden reisen manchmal damit
diese liebe fällt meine lieben freunde
und zwar ist dort eine holztreppe zu
renovieren und eine person fragt ich
kann helfen den tischler ganz lieb der
tür beantwortet wie würden sie denn bei
dieser treppe vorgehen abreißen
oder abreisen aus böbing dem 1
ich muss habe den tisch wo stetig auch
kaufen stuhl da halo biete auf rück
wörter aller angaben stehen in der
anzeige warum anzeige bietet nichts
polizei ja muss man immer die polizei
einschalten das hier ist der nächste
gegenstand der auf ebay verkauft wird
und wir sehen schon das ist von putz
einmal mit dem ausbringen gingen rechts
daneben das sind ganz gute kombination
ist hab ich bei mir in meiner bude in
hamburg auch es ist allerdings rein
gestellt worden mit dem tippen putzeimer
mit integrierter salatschleuder zu
verschenken bruder
wenn du dir da drinnen salat machst
dann wird er auf jeden fall sauber wie
teuer soll sowas sein was benötigen sie
denn genau einen autoaufkleber ja was
denn genau also je nachdem wie teuer sie
sind würde ich mehr nehmen aber auf
jeden fall würde ich einmal schon halt's
maul du peuple fresser nehmen
beim nächsten die befehle es eine person
richtig lieb unterwegs und zwar sorgte
sich richtig um die gesundheit seiner
mitmenschen und hat eine alltags mast
meister ich nehme hatten wieder auf 2000
jahre später dann bitte auch nicht mehr
nerven denn wir haben ja hier ein
bundesverdienstkreuz zu verleihen und
eine person die einer alltags maske
beziehungsweise einen mundschutz
gehäkelt hat er verkauft die für 8 euro
für handelbare preis und so sieht sie
aus
das ist super super gegen korona ist
klasse was auch das ist es das hier
und so fragte jemand hallo ist die
wohnung noch zu haben hallo haben sie
die anzeige gelesen ich suche eine
wohnung und biete keine an unfassbar
man will aber auch verarscht wo man nur
hinguckt
als recht frech das recht frech was auch
frech ist ist es nächste ebay ding
verkaufte mich jemand louis beton
taschen
das ja
diekmann
einfach mal kurz mitnehmen für wenn man
dann
mama ich war
als ss 20 uhr
die haben in hamburg auch nicht länger
mit sich warf
ja
hab ich ja wie hast du dir auch noch
neue zahlen seine kaufmann michael
eckert der war hier verkauft jemand ein
aquarium mit unterschrank und besatz und
eine person die das ganze ding kaufen
will schreibt hallo bin leider schüler
würden ein kantinen für alles 30 euro
zahlen meint aber würde es abholen
dann schreibt am tag danach noch mal
fünf fragezeichen nein tut mir leid
antwortet dann die person die das
aquarium verkauft und daraufhin der
schüler wieder es muss ihnen nicht leid
tun wirklich nicht das möchte ich nicht
jetzt tut es mir leid dass es mit leid
tut man tut mir das ganze auch irgendwie
ein bisschen leiden dass jetzt der
nächste werfen und zwar verkauft hat
eine person einen volkswagen golf bzw
wie er ihn beschrieben hat einen
wolfhagen büro vier 1.9 tdi für 1250
euro ich für die 1300 geben dann kauft
auch noch ein paar duden dazu und beim
nächsten ebay verkauft eine person seine
playstation 4
der sinn am verkaufen ist ja
dass man geld will
und nicht tauschen will dennoch
versuchte jemand sein glück und schreibt
hält haus du auch gegen was eine ps4 1
terabyte die von mir ist doch auch eine
ein terabyte ps4 meine ist aber eine
normale und keine pro jahr aber wieso
soll ich gegen eine schlechtere tauschen
kann ja sein dass du dumm bist kann ja
mal vorkommen machen wir weiter mit
diesem ebay verkauft hat jemand sein
iphone 6 und ein interessent fragt ihn
kann man damit auf whatsapp gehen ja
wirklich ja kann man okay
es ist dann wieder meine mama so
soll man lieber kurz anrufen
lassen wir
genau in dem moment schreibt mir eine
nachricht lukaschik mir ein bild von der
nation sein
hier verkauft jemand einen babykost wer
die personen hat das allerdings sind ja
nicht so ganz verstanden der
rechtschreibung und benennen das ganze
denen baby code wärmer
ja wenn man
die scheiße von seinem baby dann noch
mal kurz aufwärmen will oder so machen
wir weiter mit nächstenliebe er fehlt
uns verspätet eine person um halb neun
sie müssen bei bla bla bla bla
nummer
der verkäufer schreibt dem käufer auf
jeden fall um halb neun das er bei dem
und dem klingelschild klingen soll eine
stunde später fragte ihn dann allerdings
kommen sie dennoch samstag 9 uhr am
samstag 9 uhr und es ist 9.30 es ist
freitag
heute samstag komme
die haben wir heute zeitlich verstrahlte
menschen rechtschreiben verstrahlte
menschen grammatikalisch verstrahlte
menschen und allgemein verstrahlte
menschen dazu gehört unter anderem eine
kann man so rum kommen jetzt nicht wir
sind nicht da wären 30 minuten da
beziehungsweise 20 minuten
ich bin jetzt da wir sind nicht da wir
sie mit der familie unterwegs bei hasen
lassen sich nicht danach dass ich das
nicht anders meine fresse herr
gesangsverein
warum sagt man herr gesangsverein was
macht das finden
nächstenliebe verkauft eine person sein
wg zimmer also er möchte quasi neuen wg
mitbewohner haben und suchten über ebay
und die arme person schreibt ihm halt
die nachricht hallo wann kann ich es
sehen freuen wenn sie erstmal etwas zu
sich sagen können ich kann jetzt wie
heißen sie denn überhaupt wie alt sind
sie und sind sie auch student es geht
hier nur um ein zimmer in einer wg nein
ich bin kein student ich habe eine
familie und sie wollen mit ihrer familie
in das zimmer einziehen
wenn ich mit meiner familie
in ein wg zimmer gezogen wäre dann hätte
die wg auf jeden fall genug zahnseide da
mal keine sorgen kommen allerdings auch
schon zum letzten ebay für heute und
zwar möchte dort eine person mit einem
sehr sehr sehr sehr coolen namen
nintendos switch kaufen und fragt
dementsprechend hai gilt das angebot
noch liebe grüße bitte einmal anständig
dafür bewerben sehr geehrter piep mein
name ist luca und ich habe schon mein
ganzes leben davon geträumt ihre
nintendos switch abkaufen zu können
meine besonderen stärken sind
kreativität belastungsfähigkeit ehrgeiz
teamfähigkeit und kreativität
kreativität hat er dann einfach zweimal
dahin geschrieben
der klassische luca man kennt ihn ich
freue mich schon auf unsere zukünftige
gemeinsame transaktion bis bald und mit
freundlichen grüßen luca mensch und an
der stelle meine lieben freunde will ich
das heutige video dann auch komplett
beenden hits wie nur was fragen
jetzt genau in dem moment geschrieben
hatte alter natürlich meinen kopf
genommen
kobe bryant vom balkon runter und dann
hätte ich unten im garten der zahnseide
benutzen